when you lift weights you're not just
training your muscles you're also
training your bones you're training your
brain and you're training your
flexibility and you're training your
energy in your heart and you're training
your tendons and your connective tissue
so tendons will always be trained when
you lift weights but as with all of
those other things it's also a good idea
to do specific training for your tendons
if you want to get the very most out of
your body not only will training your
tendons prevent injury but it'll make
you more explosive it will increase your
maximum strength your ability to make
use of all that muscle power that you've
built so in other words if you intend on
getting stronger
you need tend on strength oh dear
so tendon strength can often be a
limiting factor in physical performance
so a war log on this channel for
instance I talked about a gene doping
technique that could block myostatin my
stuff and being a molecule that prevents
the building of muscle we encourage us
to be broken down it prevents it from
getting too big when you block this
muscle gets bigger naturally however
what I didn't go into in depth there was
that the knockout mice that had the
myostatin removed were more likely to
experience tendon injuries and part of
that might be because tendons actually
require myostatin myostatin plays a
maintenance role in tendons and
ligaments however it could also be that
the muscles have outpaced the tendon
strength thus leading to injury and this
is also what we see in a lot of people
who use anabolic steroids they grow
their muscles too quickly and as a
result their form far more likely to
experience tendon injury so if you build
muscle then you need to make sure you're
building the tendons at the same rate
and what anabolic steroids or myostatin
do is they exacerbate a problem that
already exists and that's that we don't
have as much blood flow to the tendons
and to the ligaments as we do for the
muscles and that means that the tendons
they take a lot longer to grow stronger
to develop more power as compared with
the muscle so if you go to the gym and
start lifting weights regularly then
you'll see structural changes in your
muscle within eight days so you should
start to see progress pretty quickly but
in the tendons you don't start to see
any structural change
for at least two months so that explains
why a lot of people are super eager head
to the gym start lifting really heavily
they get tendon injuries because their
muscles mean that they can start lifting
heavier weights but their tendons aren't
ready yet and they injure themselves so
in order to prevent this we need to make
sure that we ease ourselves in to
exercise see kids don't have so much for
a problem with tendon injuries and
that's because they're constantly
running the constant jumping climbing
playing games however adults we tend to
spend a lot of time sitting at a
computer not doing very much sitting on
a couch so our tendons on getting that
regular exercise that regular
stimulation and then suddenly we hit the
gym and we start lifting big heavy
weights is no wonder that you're going
to experience some kind of problem so
what we need to do before we start
lifting heavy weights is to ramp up our
physical exercise with lots of high
volume lots of light weights just to get
the body moving again and to build up
the tendon strength to support the heavy
weights that are going to be moving
around later on so frequency and volume
is one of the most important things when
you're starting out in order to
strengthen your tendons and doing a lot
of pump work is good as well because as
I said part of the problem here is blood
flow heading to that connective tissue
the good news is that tendons also are
much slower to lose that strength after
you finish training so that means that
you can switch from a higher volume
light lighter weight kind of program to
a more intensity based program later on
once you've built that stable base of
tendon strength and also do pump work
that means very high repetition light
weights just like the stuff I talked
about for vascularity training all of
those techniques you know long supersets
20 repetitions etc with light weights
right at the beginning will increase
blood flow to the tendons and therefore
help them to recover more and to respond
to the stimulus of giving them by
training them if you want to see an
example of just what increasing
frequency and volume can do for your
finger strength then look no further
than rock climber a rock climber with 15
plus years of experience who regularly
uses their hands to hold their entire
weight it's going to see an increase in
tendon thickness in the hands and in the
wrists and the forearms of 62 to 76
percent so that's huge their tendons are
hugely thicker and if you want to see a
really visceral example of this they're
not no further
Alex Honnold professional rock climber
who just has these beefy huge fingers I
found out that reference for our Marx
Daily Apple a great website with lots of
useful tips on building tender strength
so I'll link to that in the description
down below another excellent tool for
preventing injury in the tendons is slow
eccentrics that simply means holding the
weight and then lengthening the muscle
as you gradually lower it and studies
show that for instance people suffering
from achilles tendonitis can restore
normal function ality reduced pain by
using things like slow eccentrics on
heel dips so along with your pump work
and your increased volume you also want
to be doing these slow eccentric
starting with a light weight and if you
do all this then over two months you
should build up an excellent base of
strength so that we can start loading on
the weights now that you're confident
that your tendons and your ligaments are
ready for that increased weight how are
we going to maximize the strength and
power of our tendons so that we can lift
more and so that we have more long-term
strength even as we get older and our
muscles start to weaken so one thing you
can do is find ways to lift heavier then
your muscles can lift so your tendons in
theory can take more weight than your
muscles so if you can put yourself under
that load even without having to lift
yourself to get there then you can
stress the tendons enough to cause
massive growth this is something that we
see in the studies that you do need to
apply stress to the tendons in order to
see the most growth remember this is
only once we've built up enough
resilience in our tendons through a
frequent and lightweight training
program that we've done for a while so
this is more of an advanced technique so
things you can do to lift more than you
can lift include using hangs obviously
using slow- so you cheat your way up or
you're getting assists to get your way
up and then you just lower await that
you can't lift overcoming isometrics
which i always talk about or something
like partials the YouTuber alpha destiny
talks about partials all the time he
loves them he does lots of rack pulls
over the knee and if you check out his
channel well then his results speak for
themselves so the idea is what you're
doing is instead of doing the full range
of motion you're starting the weight
much higher up or lower
or your finishing before you do the full
range of motion and a lot of people will
say well full range motion is really
good and yes it is in fact we've just
seen that stretching the muscle with
something like a hill dip can be very
good for building tendons but so too if
you want that strength can just loading
that with lots of weight and if you
can't do a deadlift with you know
whatever this insane weight is then you
might be able to do a rack pull because
you're pulling it a much shorter
distance and what this is doing is it's
still putting those tendons under that
huge load still thickening and
strengthening them at the same time this
is also a great way of busting plateaus
because it teaches you to be more
confident with a really heavy weight and
that makes a huge difference so I've
been doing it with bench press for
instance I just put the the pins in the
rack high up lift the barbell off lower
it and then they hit the rack then I
just push it back up that way I can put
myself under a heavier weight than I
could normally manage on my own
heavier them all my 1 rep max or my 1
rep max so that I don't risk trapping
myself and then I can just put it back
and I've experienced that really heavy
weight and my tendons have experience
that really heavy weight and it builds
strength and like I say if you check out
his channel you'll see that he's
developed a huge amount of strength this
way another similar technique you can
use is something called accommodating
resistance and what this means is that
you're using a form of resistance that's
going to get heavier as you get to the
easier portion of the range of motion so
for instance you'd be doing a bench
press where it's lighter when it's close
to your chest and it's heavier when it's
further from your chest so how might you
achieve this well one option is to use
reverse bands so bands are attached to
the top of the rack and then when
they're lowered down there's less slack
so the bar feels lighter and as you lift
them higher up that they then become
slack and you're lifting the entire
weight another option is to use chain so
if you hang chains off the edges of the
barbell then when you lower the barbell
the chains pile up on the floor and when
you raise it again you're lifting more
and more of the chain on top of the
barbell and once again you can't count
this as your one direct max because it
is cheating but it's a fantastic way to
put your tendons and your connective
tissue in your bones under that huge
load and at the same time to build that
confidence to build the supporting
muscles that balance and you
it will improve your one rep max when
you do the full range of motion and
there's nothing to stop you from doing
it at all different ranges of motion to
hit the weak parts that you're
struggling with etc I didn't have chains
so what I did was I used a weighted belt
for this example I was doing dips and
then when I went low enough the weight
rested on the floor when I got high
enough they picked up along with me
there's also a chance that by doing this
you're overriding or inhibiting the
Golgi tendon organs this is a somewhat
see the scientific concept it's a little
bit controversial and the Goldi tendon
or there's a lot more complicated and
void involved in a lot of fine muscle
movement then a lot of people give it
credit for however we do know that
goggly tendon organ may play a role in
shutting off strength when it thinks
you're lifting too heavy when it thinks
that the contraction is too great and
you're gonna risk injury so by training
yourself to use heavier weights the idea
is that you're training the gorgon Golgi
tendon organ to shut up so that you can
lift heavier without it saying oh dear
and shutting off your all of your
strengths a lot of people will say that
you know when you're lifting a weight so
you're doing bench press and then
suddenly you lose all your strength it's
not like you gradually get smaller get
weaker you suddenly drop it and your
spot has to step in they say that's the
Golgi tendon organ I say whether or not
that's true remains to be seen but
whatever the mechanism using these
partials does seem to be a good way of
overriding your psychological barriers
building up more strength in the
connective tissue and the supporting
muscles etc so I highly recommend giving
it go actually there's just a lot of
value to occasionally putting yourself
under or over a really big amount of
weight you can feel the body responding
to that it's great for grip - yes
weighted stretching also is very
effective and that makes sense too
because really weight is stretching is
the natural progression natural
evolution of weighted eccentric slow
eccentric so that just basically means
using an increased range of motion where
you start to feel a stretch whilst under
some kind of resistance I've done a
whole video on that so check that out
and studies again show this can build
more strength in attendance for instance
doing a decline squat has been shown to
be more effective at building strength
and rehabilitating tendons than the
regular squat so this is something to
bear in mind
and that's the other thing to consider
with these rock climbers they're not
just rock climbing regularly they're
also under a whole lot of weight and we
see that they're either in a crimp
position or a fulcrum so they're
stretching their tendons and they're
also holding a lot of weight in a kind
of crimped position with no range of
motion so we're just mimicking that for
the rest of the body so now we know that
the tendons play a very important role
in building maximal strength and we know
how to train for that specifically by
using weighted stretching and by using
just huge amounts of weight through
overcoming isometrics or hangs or
partials however our tendons also play a
big role in explosive movements and
that's because they have a kind of all
of our connective tissue has a kind of
rebound it's very elastic and this is
called hysteresis and the lower your
hysteresis the more efficient you'll be
be less energy it will require for you
to run jump etc because of more of that
Energy's being returned for a kind of
rebound effect
so actually tendons play big much bigger
role in the biomechanics of many
movements that you might at first think
so for instance when we're running when
we're sprinting if you look at the
activation of the muscles you probably
notice there's less activation in the
calves than you might think and that's
because the Achilles tendon is actually
doing a lot of work
simply by rebounding by storing and
returning the energy so that the calf
muscle you're not actually generating so
much energy you're just bouncing off of
the tarmac and if you look at animals
like cheetahs like lepers that run super
fast what you'll notice is that they
don't have huge calves they have huge
tendons and in fact the military are
looking into building you know stilts
things like the power risers that kind
of mimic this tendon in order to give us
greater speed so building more strength
lowering the hysteresis in the Achilles
tendon would help to improve your
running speed perhaps and more so than
building more calf strength and when you
think about it this way it might make
more sense not to refer to muscles
individually or individual muscle groups
but rather empty use which are muscle
tendon units they work as a whole so
tendon can be stiff meaning that it's
thicker and it rebounds it stores more
energy but a tendon can also be more
flexible or you call that compliant more
compliant meaning that it's easier to
stretch some tendons you want to be
stiffer some tendons you want to be more
compliant depending on your biomechanics
and once again we start to see ya
interference principle come into play
here because depending on the types of
actions you use whether you're a tennis
player whether you're a swimmer whether
you're a martial artist you're going to
see different balances of stiffness and
compliance in different tendons
different connective tissue throughout
your body
and of course it's not just your tendons
that play a role in this but other types
of connective tissue - so your tendons
connect muscle to bone of course your
ligaments connect bone to bone they're
responsible for your joints and then you
have your muscle fascia which is kind of
like a shrink wrap that surrounds all
your muscle and surrounds your internal
organs and muscle fascia also might play
a role in this kind of rebound effect by
helping you to return that energy from a
depth jump for instance and of course
the way we train this once again is
simply said specific adaptations to
impose demands set at million times if
you want to train for something you do
that thing so in this case you do the
movement that you want to become more
explosive in an explosive manner I love
explosive training I've talked about it
a lot I've also talked about how
eccentric training can improve your
explosiveness likewise so you can heavy
weights so if you throw an explosive
training to things like clapping
press-ups depth jumps you know box jumps
burpees that kind of thing then you're
gonna see more explosiveness and you're
gonna build that kind of rebound that
stiffness in the tendons but at the same
time in other areas if you want to
prevent injury or if you just want to
improve your flexibility then train
stretching and think about how they're
working to support one another but also
against one another and finally the last
piece of the puzzle is diet
and recovery we've seen there's less
blood flow to the tendons and the
ligaments so of course they need longer
to recover and if they injured in any
way they need even more time to recover
typically you should try and leave 48
hours between workouts targeting
specific areas that are very heavy or
very explosive and this will give your
attendance and your ligaments and your
muscle faster time to recover at the
same time you want to try and enhance
blood flow to those areas if you can
especially if they're injured so if you
use a cold compress you'll reduce
swelling but if you use heat then you
can encourage blood flow so one thing
you can do is to use contrast therapy
that means like a shower where you
very hot and very cold in you know one
at a time in order to not only reduce
swelling but also improve blood flow
massage and self myofascial release
might also encourage blood flow to those
areas you will increase the amount of
collagen in your body so consume vitamin
C this has been shown to increase that
along with calcium and I'll go into this
in more detail in future I'm doing a
video soon on healing and also recommend
you check out my video on recovery watch
those and combine it this kind of
training and you should start to see
your tendons become stronger thicker
more resilient to injury more explosive
and that will benefit you in every
aspect of your performance so thanks a
ton for watching guys I hope you found
something useful and interesting it was
actually one of the most requested
videos on this channel along with how to
increase your healing which I am getting
to so kind of makes you wonder if you
guys are all injured you know be careful
out there if you found this video useful
and interesting then please leave a like
please share around comment down below
let me know if I missed anything any
tips that you have any suggestions for
future videos head over to the Facebook
page where you can enjoy joining in with
the conversation and giving me more
suggestions follow me on Instagram want
to see my training or Twitter if you
wanna hear my random musings head over
to the blog there's the fuller version
of this in a blog post format so check
that out as long as as well as the other
articles and subscribe hit the bell
button for notifications stay tuned in
general cuz I've got lots more like this
on the way I'll be talking like I say
about healing I'm talking about mi-6
training how to be more like bond or
Jason Bourne talking about more infinity
war inspired training about real-life
super soldiers all this stuff if that
sounds good
then stay tuned I'll see you next time
thanks a ton for watching and bye for
now